welcome back to las vegas now for the
last 40 years primrose schools the
sponsors of this next segment has
successfully combined education and
entrepreneurship helping both children
and adults with their unique system
rocky spoke with them to learn how
steve welcome to las vegas now thank you
for having me we're so excited to spread
the word about primrose school so just
briefly introduce us to what you guys do
in particular
yeah primrose schools is the premier
provider of early childhood education
and care across the us and and we have
approximately 475 schools in 33 states
in fact we open our first school in
nevada in reno last year in october
which we're really excited about
um and you know as as a leader of early
childhood education and care we we
really take pride in
um you know continuing to to to advocate
for children and for families
and really making a difference out there
on the lives of those children and
families and so we're excited to be able
to come into the las vegas and reno area
and continue to open up more schools
absolutely and thank you for what you
guys are doing for our children
i love this unique model for school so
can you explain why you're looking for
business leaders and entrepreneurs in
the valley in the las vegas area
yeah so there's a bunch of
differentiators for primrose schools
i'll just touch on two so number one is
we have what we call our balanced
learning approach and so we have this
belief at primrose that who children
become
is just as important as what they know
and it's really that that balance
between
you know the education side as well as
the character development you know the
compassion the caring the kindness
and so our uh balanced learning approach
is proprietary it's actually developed
in partnership with some of the leading
early childhood experts out there in the
universities across the u.s as well as
our in-house team
and it's really set up so that franchise
owners and schools don't have to worry
about worrying about lesson plans or
what to teach each week we take care of
all that for them
which is which is really really helpful
and then the second piece i would call
out is what you talked about and that is
entrepreneurs
so so each of our schools are owned and
operated by individual franchise owners
in the markets and in where those
schools are and the children and
families that they serve and you're also
helping entrepreneurs you're helping you
know people with business minds who are
maybe taking a new step in their careers
or a new path i should say
that's exactly correct and in fact the
majority of our franchise owners uh had
never been in early childhood education
had never been in franchising before
didn't even know about franchising to
your point and what's exciting about it
is we have a we have a lot of franchise
owners that you know they decided hey i
want to re-career i want to do something
different i want to make a bigger
difference in the community in which i
live and they had this passion
that they were able to harness within
within the primo school system what's
great when you think about the las vegas
and reno markets our teams are already
out there curating additional locations
for schools
and so if it's something that
you're interested in and and you're like
you know how how long is this going to
take um there's a lot of times we can
get franchise owners into schools within
eight to nine months our goal in in this
uh this whole journey is
how do we raise great citizens of the
world and and primrose provides the
tools for franchise owners to be able to
do that
thank you again to primrose schools for
sponsoring this segment for more
information or for franchise
opportunities you can call 800 primrose
or visit franchise.primroseschools.com
las vegas now